flynn's sister loaned him some money and
he paid her back over time flynn graphed
the relationship between how much time
had passed in weeks since the loan and
how much money he still owed his sister
what feature of the graph represents how
long it took flynn to pay back the loan
pause this video see if you can figure
that out
all right now let's go through each of
each of these choices so the first one
is the slope
so the slope tells us how much do we
change in the vertical direction for any
given change in the horizontal direction
so for example if we start from here we
can see that if
one week goes by we go from one week to
two weeks we can see that our loan went
down it went from fifteen dollars to ten
dollars so when we had plus one weeks in
time
our loan went down by
five dollars and then that happens
over the next week and that rate of how
quickly the loan is paid that's what the
slope tells us and it would be constant
over the course of the entire time
period is what is what makes this align
is that that slope is always going to be
constant so the slope is useful for the
rate at which the loan is being paid
back but it's not the clearest way to
figure out how long it took flynn to pay
back the loan so i would rule that one
out
the x-intercept that's where the graph
intersects the horizontal axis which is
often referred to as the x-axis
now or another way to think about it
that tells us that says what is what is
the x-value when our vertical value our
y value is equal to zero and our y value
is the money owed so it says hey how
much time has passed when we owe when we
don't owe any more money or when flynn
doesn't owe any more money to a sister
well that's exactly what they're asking
for how long did it take flynn to pay
back the loan and that's what that
x-intercept tells us it took him four
weeks after four weeks he didn't owe any
more money to his sister so i like this
choice but let's just review the other
ones the y-intercept well that's where
the graph intersects the y-axis right
over there
this tells us what's going on at time t
equals zero at time t equals zero or
time equals zero when the horizontal
variable is equal to zero we see that
flynn owes twenty dollars so this one
isn't valuable for figuring out when he
how long it takes to pay it back this
one is useful for figuring out how much
did he owe initially so we'll rule that
one out and we already picked one choice
so we could rule out none of the above